welcome to versus the games my show that
pits your favorite games consoles
franchises and hot-button issues against
each other this week we're diving into
the switch's burgeoning Metroidvania
scene as we compare dead cells and
hollow knight to help you figure out
which game is right for you right time
to get into the debate
[Music]
it's official the switch is the new via
now if you're cynical that might sound
like I'm saying that it's a console that
didn't sell very well even though it's
got some good games what I actually mean
is I love a Vita it's got some of the
coolest in the experiences of all times
and it just so happens that this month
this switch has started to feel like a
via to me - via - year and I mean that
we've like the most praise possible not
only does this console have the games
that I want but like they're also good
specifically the games that we're
talking about today my favorite right
now is dead cells yours is I'm playing
hollow nights yeah so we're going to
talk about those two because I think
between us we agree that those are the
two best games on this console they're
like representative of the metroidvania
format right yeah if you're after that
experience they both do it really well
but slightly differently yeah and that's
what we kind of want to talk about like
what do you like about polynomials I
mean the first thing I noticed about
hollow night was how it looked and
immediately I knew that I wanted it
because it's just like totally my
aesthetic it's this creepy bug guy in a
cave underground with a sword yes the
thing is it that's basically what I look
for in every game so I knew as soon as I
saw it that I wanted this game and I
heard it was coming to switch and I was
holding out on holding it and holding
out because I think the switch is such
the perfect platform for these games so
like Halle Knight is I mean the term
that people use to describe it is a
Metroidvania and it yeah it is very much
like that but like what does that mean
and what kind of experience are you
getting out of it what is bringing you
back to it so it does have the the
classic Metroidvania style of gameplay
which is exploring the world and you're
coming up to the places that you can't
quite get to yet because you might not
have the right abilities or the skill
level and you're exploring and your
character is constantly like upgrading
their skills and abilities and things
and it doesn't so have sort of Dark
Souls influences there as well when you
die you drop all of your currency in a
ghost form of yourself and you have to
go back to that ghost and get
you actually have to fight your ghost to
get back your currency and which is
essentially how you upgrade yourself
similar to Dark Souls I guess you
upgrade your character by yet popping
your soul level and buying things with
souls in this it's with the currency of
the world so it's all dependent on you
maintaining that level of currency which
adds an extra level of peril to the
metroidvania former parliament sounds
like it's a pure representation of the
metroidvania format with some
sprinklings of Dark Souls whereas dead
cells feels like it's got influences
from castlevania metroid and Dark Souls
by also kind of like takes everything
and tweaks it a bit and adds in like
elements of roguelike to kind of change
it all into something that feels
completely unique even though it's made
up of really familiar parts so it's got
a lot of that same stuff where you
explore and you kind of you know you
grow your character and you come up
against areas where you're like I can't
do this yet because I don't have the
right abili but at the same time it's
got that peril of Dark Souls where when
you get killed you're the stuff that you
actually have collected during that run
is gone forever but what happens is some
of it like weapons like if you find a
blueprint you kind of it gets stored
into your permanent inventory that gets
kind of like is represented in the
starting zone like it's everything's
held in jars and that kind of stuff and
then what it does is it kind of like
grabs a couple of those like it gives
you those and and Chuck's it and so like
every time you go through it feels
unique and that's one of the things that
I think differentiates dead cells from
hollow knights so there's some where
randomization to each run or pin you
sort of say oh I like playing like this
and I want to keep doing that is there a
way to sort of carry on playing I think
that's that's the kind of the
interesting part about it is like you'll
never you'll never feel comfortable
always from the outset you'll have a set
of tools and abilities and mutations and
grenades that you're really comfortable
with but the game kind of forces you to
play with other things so you get a
little more familiar familiar with those
as well so that you're not like feeling
completely
you know out of sorts when you get that
stuff instead of the stuff you want and
like I really like the progression
system in that in this game like it
feels like it's got a risk and reward to
it as well
you know what's the progression like in
in Holland so as you make your way
through the world you just randomly
discover new abilities which can upgrade
your character you can upgrade the
weapon you can upgrade how you move so
you can - and you can sort of do this
like dive bomb attack and you can also
find charms and charms there's like a
limited number of slots that you can
fill with charms and each one gives you
different abilities as you work your way
through the game yes some are given to
you from like the bosses and things
others are just completely random and
one of the beautiful things about Halle
Knight is it's really up to you like how
you make your way through the world do
you tackle this boss now or do you try
and upgrade your abilities first and
then go back to tackle it later
that's that's one thing that is missing
from dead cells that doesn't necessarily
make it a worst game or anything in dead
cells like there are key areas which
will always appear okay and there are
paths through through the world like you
know you could you have like Forks in
the road and that kind of stuff and
those are generally defined but the kind
of each individual screen and they're
like individual area as you're going
along that is procedurally generated and
the enemies are kind of randomly placed
as well so every time you come back to a
place it has a slight familiarity like
the music is similar the aesthetic and
the kind of like theme of the world is
similar but the actual physical layout
is different and I really like that
I didn't originally straightaway I was I
wanted that familiarity from it from a
Metroidvania where cuz then you feel
like you're gaining mastery over the
world right yeah growing you know yeah
you know where you are and know where
you should be going so do you feel like
your loss at all or you do kind of the
thing that remedies that is the growth
of your character okay so as you grow
you get these permanent unlocks and
abilities and that kind of stuff that
stick with you and what happens is it
eventually you reach the point where
you'll instead of where where in a
previous run you'd come to like a dead
end but there's an ability that you need
to progress a few runs later you reach
that similar point but this time you've
got the ability okay so it's like it's
it's almost like having that that kind
of the metroidvania moment where you
need an ability and then coming back
later but like stumbling on upon it
randomly the thing that has got
familiarity now the way kind of like
gives you the feeling of mastery over
the world and the comfort is the combat
there's a lot of it in that and again
like we're gonna be talking about Dark
Souls a lot every every time and I mean
this 2018 all games are Dark Souls very
much pretty much it's like the first
time you'll catch you by surprise
the second time like you'll notice it
coming and then you'll figure out how
best to deal with it whether it's trying
to like preemptively stop them from
doing it or rolling through them because
you've got like a lot of invincibility
frames the third time third run-through
then it's not even a problem so like
you're familiar with the enemies
in one area then the game does this
really cool thing where it's like it
starts throwing loads of enemies at you
so it's like you know all the behaviors
but can you deal with all of them at
once so then it's like oh crap I've
gotta say it's kind of building that
dexterity so it's even though when
you're but when you're becoming familiar
with the with the enemies it's still
challenging you what is what is it like
in hollow Knight though because I the
thing that I see about it like I'm gonna
play Halle Knight I've got it and want
to play more of it but like after
playing this and seeing or feeling how
engaging the combat is I'm a little
worried that it might feel a bit simple
yeah looking at dead cells it did look a
bit more frantic in terms of how much is
going on on the screen at any one time a
whole night I think there's a bit
simpler at least at the moment like I'm
about ten hours into the game and it is
challenging it is challenging in that
you need to be patient with combat you
need to sort of watch your enemy which
is for a 2d platforming game it's not
something I'm usually used to and I'm
used to sort of running through you and
just hacking everyone to bits but
actually you need to take every single
enemy seriously because you know you
have a limited amount of Health a lot of
it is about learning the patterns of
enemies and how they move so you do
learn to appreciate the enemies in each
area in terms of how you're attacking I
think it's a lot more limited than dead
cells you talk about lots of different
weapons and dead cells but you just have
your needle in the hollow knife which
you can upgrade and but then you do
learn different spells but I think it's
a lot slower to introduce you to those
and you don't have them all at any one
time like you know you have these charms
that you can activate new spells and
things so it's up to you to decide how
you want to tailor your combat to the
area you're in or how you feel more
comfortable playing so yeah it's quite
sort of methodical and you have to take
your time with it and it's there there
can be quite a few enemies that you have
to fight and think about like how do you
help maneuver them as well as defeat
them because they might only take three
or four hits but it's all about timing
and
how you can get around them rather than
just sort of pure destructive yeah it
does seem like the combat in Hana is a
little more deliberate because of the
random the randomized element of various
parts of dead cells it requires you to
really quickly change tack and change
direction depending on what you got and
I think that's all part of it trying to
teach you the different styles of
playing like it's not something that it
does like almost like within a framework
it's not being like now it's time to
learn the defense style is something
that you pick up yeah and like you've
become a well-rounded player because of
it because by the time you're done
you're like any weapon that you throw at
me I'm generally gonna be okay with it
so it feels like there's a lot more
moving parts to there dead cells and I
think that's probably one of the
distinctions that will kind of weed make
and when you're trying to figure out
which one you want sure like this feels
way more action heavy and like fast and
kind of like Arcadia almost where that
feels like a little more of the measured
and take your time you've got loads of
tools at your disposal figure it out and
then go for it
I think like the one downside that I I
wouldn't even call it a downside it's
just the one thing to know about dead
cells before you pick you up is although
it's awesome and all of this stuff it
still has that feeling of when you die
you start with nothing right even though
you're given stuff fairly quickly like
here's your thing and here's your thing
that that feeling of being killed and
then having to start over again and
repeat things for some people it turns
them off I personally think that the
loop is strong enough that even if you
tend to think that you know you don't
like that stuff it's worth still trying
if you can borrow it off someone or like
see if you can watch it with some videos
or you know whatever it takes but like
check it out anyway because I feel like
the loop is so strong and the gameplay
feels so tight and it's so satisfying
that that all comes together to kind of
negate the the kind of I'm dead I'm
trying it again because you're having so
much fun going through yeah I think it's
important for a roguelike to make you
feel like even though you've just died
you have to start over you have made
some progress in some way and obviously
Halle Knight doesn't really have that
roguelike element what would you say it
is like the one thing that people should
keep in mind when buying discs for that
that death thing in Steiner over again
is the one caveat I put on dead cells do
you have something similar for all on it
I'd say it is challenging in places some
people get two feet of a boss once and
turn the game off I've been committed
that sometimes but if you put your mind
to it it is all about like attack
patterns and dodging and things is so
you can get through it and I think if
you like that sort of experience and you
want to go on a little mini adventure
underground with this tech man yeah I'd
say it's definitely well yeah yeah and
what we're saying is if you like docks
oh yeah I think what we're actually
saying is like regardless of which one
you pick you are in for a good game yeah
and also like the switch is amazing for
Metroidvania right now like between holo
night dead cells Celeste salt and
sanctuary I think oh boy shovel knight
any of those games are amazing these are
our favorites right now
if you're interested in any of them we
thoroughly recommend checking them out
either way like we said you're in for a
really good time both super-strong games
if you need further convincing you can
read reviews of them on GameSpot if you
go to our YouTube channel you can see
video reviews and video gameplay of it
so you don't have to just take our word
for it take the worlds of word for it
what does I mean so that's our
discussion about two of our favorite
Metroidvania is the elves in Hanoi and
replaceable now let us know if you buy
any of them if you're playing any of
them what you think and we'll see you
next time
[Music]